en deux le petit déjeuner politique ce
matin c'est bruno retailleau sénateur de
vendée et président du groupe plr au
sénat oui bonjour bruno retailleau
bonjour patrick roger on avance vers les
fêtes de fin d'année qu'attendez-vous
com annonce des manuels mâcon sur le
déconfinement j'attends deux choses jeu
j'attends de la clarté c'est à dire que
j'attends une perspective parce
qu'aujourd'hui les français souffrent
psychologiquement parce que nous n'avons
pas de perspectives on sait rien il ya
une cacophonie d'ailleurs souvent dans
les ministres qui se contredisent et
puis j'attends du bon sens les français
ne comprennent rien du tout aux règles
bureaucratiques le gouvernement a édicté
comment voulez vous qu'ils comprennent
que l'on puisse être autorisé à acheter
deux bouteilles de vin chez un caviste
et et non pas un livre chez un libraire
c'est incompréhensible
mais vous comprenez quand même la
prudence aussi de jean castex entre les
avis médicaux qu'il peut avoir et puis
la première sortie du déconfinement qui
n'a pas été la meilleure des réussites
visiblement quand même et qu'il ait
loupé le confinement le déconfinement le
des continents
mais il n'est pas obligé de faire payer
de ses erreurs l'ensemble des français
je m'explique je pense qu' aucune étude
épidémiologique n'a montré que les
commerces de proximité
c'était des foyers de contagion de
contamination on le sait bien il ya même
une étude américaine très sérieux de
l'université de stanford qui est parue
dans nature qui dit l'un vertes parce
que on peut contrôler les choses dans un
petit commerce de proximité
10 et du coup on se retrouve dans un il
y a aussi les galeries marchandes où il
ya tous les commerces aujourd'hui en
fait le petit commerce il est pas qu en
coeur de ville
il est dans les galeries marchandes ou
mais il ya beaucoup de chasseurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que dès les prochains jours le
gouvernement devrait donner une
perspective notamment au commerce en
disant écoutez vous allez à partir du 27
novembre pouvoir ouvrir à deux
conditions moi je les propose est la
première condition avec un protocole
renforcé par exemple en vérifiant que au
nombre de mètres carrés par exemple six
ou sept mètres carrés y ait une personne
les autres comme eux lorsque je vais à
la boulangerie pour acheter ma baguette
coûtait souvent j'attends à l'extérieur
très bien ok et puis ensuite en donnant
la main aux préfets les préfets c'est à
dire en territoriale territorialisées il
vaut plus que ce soit de paris qu'on
gouverne complètement la france parce
que les préfets savent bien que
effectivement dans des galeries
marchandes là du coup on peut avoir un
entassement là ça peut être dangereux
mais franchement dans des commerces de
proximité dans nos villages et nos
villes moyennes même dans les grandes
villes
lorsqu'ils sont isolés dans une rue mais
où est le problème où est le problème
et c'est grave parce que quand les
français ne trouvent pas en face d'eux
des règles de bon sens la confiance
s'effrite mais êtes vous n'obtenez pas
leur plein consentement leur pleine
coopération pratique entre les mains
nues retailleau qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la demande de bruno le maire
de décaler le black friday de quelques
jours mais mais tout ça c'est de la
foutaise
ouais il en a le mandat mais il en a
aucun pouvoir
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que on est dans l'absurde east hants
l'absurde distance et ce royaume
autonome de france des technocrates pas
jamais les français n'avaient eu n'avait
entendu une telle pub d'ailleurs pour
black friday
mais bono le maire pas plus qu'aucun
autre membre du gouvernement n'a pas la
possibilité
le pouvoir dan 8 faire pression
peut-être sur les déceptions qu'ils ont
fait cette erreur avec les commerces de
proximité qui sont en train d'essayer de
se mélanger on qu'il devrait ouvrir le
24 alors et bien sûr est en réalité on
sait une nouvelle trouvaille pour nous
emmener sur des fausses pistes c'est
tout mais voilà c'est exactement comme
les sapins moi je connais très bien le
président national la fédération
justement des artisans français ils vont
avoir l'autorisation
vous savez les playlists
vendre des sapins coupés de noël à
l'extérieur mais ils vont pas avoir
l'autorisation de vendre des fleurs
coupées
ça veut dire que le gouvernement pense
que le sapin de noël est peut-être moins
contagieux que la fleur coupée
la pétition vous jetez pas ma zone ou
par non non j'ai pas signés alors vous
êtes contre amazon ou pas je suis pas
contre amazon moi je veux des règles
claires
attention le black friday c'est quoi
aussi c'est un chiffre d'affaires à peu
près de 6 milliards mais vous savez que
le e-commerce sur les 6 milliards
représentent seulement 1 milliard le
reste c'est du commerce ce séjour dire
physique un traditionnel donc on est en
train de tuer des petites entreprises
françaises et quand gouvernement dit y'a
pas de problème on va payer bien sûr
parce que le gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est le chèque c'est le quoi qu'il en
coûte
c'est d'ailleurs ce sera l'argent des
français et un jour cette dette faudra
bien la rembourser donc le gouvernement
pay pay pay très bien il n'a que cette
seule réponse mais les commerçants les
indépendants eux ils veulent vivre des
fruits de leur travail qu'il y ait pas
de subventions bruno retailleau il y un
sondage ifop fiducial ce matin 85% des
français craignent d'une explosion
sociale dans les prochains mois comment
l'éviter mais on l'évitera précisément
en redonnant de la confiance lac
pourquoi la confiance a été effritée
elle a été effritée d'abord parce que
pendant le premier confinement il ya eu
mensonge sur les masques ouais et sas a
abîmé la parole publique et puis ensuite
il ya ce manque de bon sens précisément
et quand vous n'avez pas des vrais à
berneck avec du bon sens il faut du bon
sens c'est autre chose
si messi messi quand je dis une l'apts
l'apts sur distance n'est pas de moi
c'est d'un grand journal allemand e on y
est on comprend plus rien du tout les
ministres se contredisent et je crois
que la france est en train de tomber
dans une dépression pas seulement
économique et social mais dans une
dépression tout court parce que le
gouvernement est mal macron c'est ce que
je lui demande d'ailleurs cette semaine
c'est de nous donner une perspective on
veut faire des efforts les français ont
ainsi vite beaucoup plus que le
gouvernement qui souvent qu'il ya
peut-être aussi les incertitudes quand
même delà de la maladie quoi et que même
s'il donne la perspective bien sûr bien
sûr il ya des certitudes
c'est pour ça que moi je plaide pour que
lien confinement alléger il faut pas
parler de déconfinement mais que enfin
enfin on devrait une vraie stratégie
une stratégie qui a été gagnante en
allemagne dans les grandes et vocal
stratégie alors les tests les tests
1 le traçage oui et l'isolément pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a des hôtels qui sont vides
bien les isolements on réquisitionne les
hôtels pour mettre les personnes malades
il vaut mieux dès lors laurent wauquiez
veuze et orléans les personnes malades
isolés tous les bien portants
ça me semble être du bon sens vous
laurent wauquiez il fallait suivre son
initiative il faudrait tester d'ici noël
toute sa région rhône alpes auvergne
je suis pas sûr que je préside peut-être
que c'est possible à l'échelle d'une
région
en tout cas avec les tests antigénique
on peut tester de façon massive pour
pouvoir isoler les malades ça c'est
clair
mais vous savez moi je me bats lorsqu'il
ya des tests salivaires un nom
départements la vendée à acheter des
machines qui sont produites en venté et
dans la technologie vient d'une
biotechnologie française sur les tests
salivaires ya toujours pas le tampon
administratif alors que c'est un test
qui est sûr à plus de 85%
encore une fois la bureaucratie
française encore une fois bon dans les
impacts
à propos de la course au vaccin aussi
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à une
vaccination obligatoire vous moi je
pense que c'est beaucoup trop tôt
d'abord il faut bien sûr quand même
qu'on ait des vaccins qui ne présente
pas d'effets secondaires il faut être
sûr qu'ils ont des vaccins qui stoppe
bien le processus de contamination au
bout du bout moi j'appelle les français
je me fais vacciner chaque année sur
pour lier la grille contre la grippe
oui je pense qu'il faudra se faire
vacciner je pense qu'il faudra des
publics prioritaires je pense que par
exemple pour les médecins soit aux
soignants près dans les ehpad dans les
hôpitaux
il faut que ce soit obligatoire en
revanche je suis très sceptique sur
notre capacité à imposer à la population
générale
une contrainte parce que comment la frat
on respecte et on ira mettre des amendes
ouais j'aimerais bien voir comment on va
faire on parle beaucoup
bruno retailleau de l'expansionnisme
turc en ce moment un emmanuel macron a
haussé le ton ces derniers jours mais
certains estiment qu'on délaisse malgré
tout la population arménienne dans le
haut-karabagh quel est votre projet de
résolution j'ai vu qu'il n'y en avait 1
au sénat qui devrait être discuté dans
quelques jours exactement et c'est une
première vous savez qu'il ya vingt ans
pratiquement la france a été de toutes
les nations du monde la première nation
notre nation française j'en suis fier à
reconnaître le génocide arménien
eh bien sans doute que pour la première
fois au sénat le 25 novembre prochain
nous allons voter
nous allons voter une résolution pour
demander justement condamné bien sûr les
agissements de monsieur erdogan est
demandée aussi une enquête
internationale pour les crimes compte de
guerre qui ont été commises la base
notamment dans le haut karabakh mais
surtout pour demander la reconnaissance
de la république du haut-karabakh
général de gaulle dans un grand discours
pendant la guerre at hamas avait indiqué
que dans ce petit pays de tout petit
pays de quelques millions personnes
c'était un peu le berceau au berceau de
la civilisation du monde et il avait dit
je le jeu le paraphrase que l'humanité
leur devais beaucoup et bien moi je suis
fier que bien sûr mon groupe mais ça va
la liste les cobistes
dans cette période monsieur erdogan
conduit une politique d'expansion nisme
islamistes et néo ottoman et
nationaliste il regardait ses
agissements en syrie contre les kurdes
regardez ces agissements aussi en libye
regardez ces agissements même au coeur
de l'europe
monsieur erdogan dimanche dernier était
à chypre un pays européen pour attiser
les braises de la division de la
fracture entre les deux stars il n'y a
pas chez les prius il n'ya pas pourquoi
et bien parce que parce qu'il ya ya pas
de fermeté ya pas de volonté et moi je
m'honore que le sénat encore une fois
c'est une démarche qui ne concerne pas
seulement mon propre groupe je l'initié
mais d'autres groupes notamment à gauche
sont venus dans cette démarche là pour
dire stop monsieur erdogan stop on vous
condamnent maintenant hein on engage un
bras de fer parce que il y en a assez de
tous ces munich qu'on n'arrête pas de
perdre en france et surtout avec
l'europe l'europe c'est celle de
l'impuissance aujourd'hui bien
heureusement en france il va y avoir une
voix du sénat qui va s'élever et qui va
dire monsieur erdogan
regardez on reconnaît vos crimes ouais
arrêté stop certains n'est qu'une voie
et ça commence par là la politique le
futur projet de loi sur le séparatisme
arrive début décembre le texte a été
baptisé project lois confortant les
principes républicains
le mot séparatisme a été enlevée bonne
idée ou pas à d'abord ça devait être un
texte contre l'islamisme ensuite pour la
les sites et maintenant c'est le respect
des principes républicains on voit bien
que dans cette valse hésitation du
vocabulaire qui a tout court une
certitude une hésitation
alors ce texte là l'idée se vend tout
n'est pas mal y crée par exemple au
titre des côtés positifs y crée un délit
de mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
à travers la diffusion par exemple sur
internet d'information qui concerne
votre vie professionnelle l'autre vit
aussi familial il crée aussi une sorte
de principe d'opposition pour la
polygamie opposable message
je m'étonne d'ailleurs que l'on soit
reconnaître dans une loi fin c'est déjà
le cas en revanche rien sur
l'immigration alors qu'il ya un lien on
le sait entre l'immigration mais mais
mais le manqueront d'ailleurs dû finir
par le reconnaître entre l'immigration
et puis
mais c'est peut-être pas le même sujet
c'est un sujet c'est le même sujet à
écouter souvenez vous qu'est ce qui
s'est passé quand même le monsieur sam
elle pâtit il était décapité par
quelqu'un d'origine russo tchétchène
le tunisien celui qui a égorgé trois
fidèles à nice le tueur de villeurbanne
avant a émis ce ne serait pas un grand
fourre-tout du coup cette loi alors si
on mettait même innovation il faut donc
été écoutées avec akron a toujours les
grands discours on a parfois des textes
de loi mais on n'a rien derrière
il faut traiter non seulement les
conséquences il faut traiter les causes
et moi je regrette qu'il n'y ait rien du
tout sur l'immigration bien sûr il faut
expulser beaucoup plus pour les
étrangers qui se trouvent notamment sur
le sol français en situation illégale
ficher s pour des milliers d'entre eux
qu'est ce qu'on fait on est le premier
pays d'europe
il faut que les pays puissent les
recevoir on fait tous les pays dont
nommer les pays des personnes ont revu
leur stratégie et ont durci leurs
conditions notamment d'immigration sur
le droit d'asile sur le regroupement
familial sur l'accès aux soins nous non
je regrette aussi que par exemple sur
les marqueurs de l'islamisme comme le
voile ou la l'université dans les
sorties scolaires y rien du tout et
voilà je je je déplore aussi que par
exemple en matière de fermeture des
mosquées
on n'est pas un dispositif législatif
plus opératoire donc là il fallait dans
l'autre ils devaient faire davantage de
pouvoirs pour pouvoir justement contre
les mauvais je veux dire que il ya de
bonnes choses qu'il faudra voter mais
très franchement évident il est maigre
et on n'a pas l'arsenal législatif
répressif et est vraiment déterminé
quand on pouvait espérer avoir un mot
aussi bruno retailleau puisqu'il y à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 également en
perspective
vous réclamez toujours une primaire
interne chez les républicains
mais christian jacob semble freiner le
réclame un processus de choix
démocratique là seulement pour les
militants bien sûr pour les militants
mais aussi pour les sympathisants voilà
je pense qu'au xxième siècle pour
l'élection la plus importante
bien les gens qui nous supportent qui
viennent coller des affiches ou qui
votent pour nous on doit leur donner la
parole
on leur a déjà donné la parole on a fait
une erreur de diagnostic on a dit oh là
là on a perdu en 2010 est à cause des
prix maintenant c'est à côté ça faire
mais il faut faire la même primaire
alors je pense alors j'ai fait des
propositions pour la modifier notamment
sur deux points
je pense qu'une primaire en deux tours
sas attend énormément ça attise les
tensions et deuxième point je pense que
on pourrait avoir un statut du
sympathisants pour que l'on puisse faire
en sorte que chacun ne puissent pas
voter quelles que soient leurs
convictions parce que en 2016 il
suffisait de signer une gens qu'il
faudrait que je veux faire opposition il
faudrait par exemple s'engager avec une
cotisation d'un statut de sympathisants
qui serait pas celui du militant ne riez
pas encarté mais vous figurez vous
accepteriez par exemple de figurer sur
un fichier voilà que ce soit et un
pillage en élection en un tour un tour
alors il peut y avoir un tout il peut y
avoir un vainqueur de type canadien
préférentiels pour que ce soit un peu
moins brutale mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que je suis ouvert simplement ne
remettons pas en cause ce principe
d'aller vers les gens et de leur
demander de prendre le mais est-ce que
vous croyez dur un choix qui engagent
leur avenir christian jacob il il freine
pas ce qui l'attend nicolas sarkozy non
mais je pense que non mais c'est son
chef nicolas sarkozy je sais que pour
beaucoup de nos militants c'est une
expérience traumatisante donc c'est
normal que christian jacob je veux dire
puisse en tenir compte
simplement je dis à figeac hop on a
perdu quand même avec la candidature
qu'on nous promettait françois baroin
pratiquement à noé mais là on va encore
perdre un an et est temps qu'on
incarnera rien du tout voilà on va
laisser monsieur macro et madame le pen
caracolait en tête des sondages pré
nicolas sarkozy et qu'il a il a un rôle
à jouer johnny mais mais nicolas sarkozy
a à ce rôle tutélaire
je ne crois pas un instant un instant à
son retour
pourquoi parce que je le crois lui et le
programme et le programme à chaque
interview il dit non un objet c'est plus
la politique
le mode afin avec cécile de ménibus
pedro le professeur est poursuivi par
l'ordre des médecins a notamment par son
traitement sur la clope la chloroquine
il est soupçonné de charlatanisme ce qui
est quand même assez énorme
il affirme lui être victime d'un complot
politique et médical
quel est votre ce que vous allez dans le
sens de cette hypothèse
non mais je suis pas du tout un
complotiste moi j'étais un exact e mans
en mars à le soutenir pour moi parce
qu'à l'époque on était dans une épidémie
qui faisait des morts et milliers de
morts nous n'avions pas accès nous avons
pas traitement et les d'auxi chloroquine
des grands médecins m'avaient indiqué
c'est pas moi bruno retailleau qui était
sorti subitement grands médecins
m'avaient indiqué écoute on en connaît
depuis des dizaines d'années on
l'administré des centaines de millions
personnes
on connaît très très bien ce médicament
les droits sont tombés dans le domaine
public et les contre indications
on les connaît tant qu' on n'a pas le
droit de refuser justement une piste qui
peut être intéressante
le débat n'est pas clos franchement
faire de lien à chauffer rencontre faire
de monsieur raoul professeur raout à
charlatans alors que il est reconnu sur
la scène mondiale comme un grand
scientifique sans doute qu'il est
particulier sans doute que l'on il a des
allures de ba de bar de sel sans doute
qui n'a pas la langue dans sa poche sans
doute se trompe-t-il parce que tout le
monde se trompe écouté il vous souvenez
les scientifiques comme horizon
franchement les diafoirus à la molière
il y en a des tonnes vous souvenez de ce
gros cette espèce était dit dans l'aisne
lance est con et décrivait justement
pour les rangs prêche les hypothèses du
professeur out qui s'est elle aussi
retrouvé une fin en tout cas c'est une
tartufferie voilà donc on alimente aussi
le complotisme cette espèce de de parole
scientifique qui a été totalement
dispersés qui a été totalement
contradictoire induit chez les gens un
doute formidable et ce doute je vais
vous dire ce qui est grave c'est qu'au
moment où il va falloir vacciner les
gens en nombre en masse et bien ceux
d'août va peser ce sera une épée de
damoclès sur la capacité des français à
avoir confiance et accepter de se faire
vacciner orci et je le redis il faut se
faire vacciner parce qu'on se protège
soi même mais surtout on protège les
autres merci bruno retailleau président
du groupe plr au sénat sénateur de
vendée était l'invité ce matin de sud
radio et dans un instant le journal huit
heures a tout de suite
sud radio sur radio paris